salles d'étude SAT prêts étudiants en arts libéraux
agencer des renflouements rêves brisés
ce n'est pas notre avenir ce sont
différents Russ tu peux inventer une application
démarrer un blog vendre des choses en ligne mes
amis et moi nous promouvons des fêtes amenez
vos amis amenez tous vos amis
s'ils ressemblent  vous les apportez tous, mais si
vous êtes un DJ, tout ce dont vous avez besoin est un ordinateur portable,
du talent sur une piste, cette piste est
votre ticket pour tout ce gars
là, bel homme là, il est EJ,
je suis Vijay, c'est juste une pièce à côté, mais
peut  Je ne joue pas ivre amoureux absolument pas
Je viens de lire sur le ciel juste quand
veges Instagram il l'a vendu avant dans un
million de dollars maintenant il avait 26 ans
vous voulez gagner de l'argent réel vous
voulez vivre et mourir dans la vallée que nous
avons  pour sortir d'ici, hé, vous savez que cette
fête est à la recherche d'un petit pas, alors qu'est-ce que
vous dites peut-être pour l'amplifier, je veux dire,
vous pouvez essayer,
c'est le travail du DJ de faire sortir la foule
de leur tête et dans leur corps,
j'aime commencer  dans environ 125
tarte  ce par minute
une fois que vous avez verrouillé leur
fréquence cardiaque, commencez à les élever chanson par chanson
128 battements par minute c'est le nombre magique
nous étions bons là-bas vous savez vraiment
comment travailler une foule en achetant quelque chose Je
vais juste sauter devant  chaque fois que vous
êtes prêts à commencer à faire du vrai Luke
vous avez besoin d'un lapin hurlant vous pensez que je
vais travailler pour ce gars vous êtes fou
c'est notre avenir hmm je veux dire Cole
on va jamais être meilleur que nous
la honte pue est vraiment talentueuse
chez un artiste à succès qu'ils ont eu ce
moment ils ont cessé d'être un admirateur
ils trouvent que leurs
sons de signature ont une âme les construisent à partir de zéro en
trouvent de nouveaux
sortez la main cet ordinateur portable ça
commence à ce que le monde réel
essaie de vous dire
nous nous rencontrons là-bas seulement chose que ça
ne marche pas comme ça
nous n'allons pas être millionnaires ça
n'arrivera pas
ce qui est arrivé à la loyauté ce que je ne suis pas
va maintenant
tout le monde est responsable d'eux-mêmes
tu as ça
si tu as un rêve  un  Et c'est fait de
tout ce qui t'a rendu difficile l'
amitié tellement d'amour c'est ton
billet pour
tout c'est mon avenir il va y avoir la
meilleure meilleure meilleure nuit de ta vie quoi
de neuf je suis Cole Carter